Today I want to look at how the global
economy will collapse
specifically how the US economy will
collapse because of this war. Now the
argument I want to make to you today is
that financial collapse do not happen
accidentally or naturally. It has to be
engineered.
And this is a very hard concept for us
to understand. Okay. So uh in economics
there's something called the boom bud
cycle
which basically states that in
capitalism you have
um the economy booming then suddenly for
whatever reason it collapses. Okay, it's
called a boom bus cycle.
And
the idea is that if you study economics,
they teach you that this is just a
natural part of capitalism because in
good times, people spend too much money.
They become overconfident.
And so then they uh waste a lot of money
and then it collapses. The the economy
turns bad. And so you have to focus on
being more lean and efficient and
resilient. So think of, you know,
gaining weight, okay? You gain too much
weight and then you feel bad. So then
you lose weight. And that's the idea of
um the boom bicycle.
The problem though is that no one can
explain properly
how and why
suddenly the bubble pops. Okay. What is
the mechanism
or trigger
for the collapse?
If you stud economics, you will never
ever know the answer. So we are going to
focus on speculation today. Okay. So
again um the internet knows this but
I've never studied economics.
I don't know much about economics
but I'm curious as to why this happens.
Okay. Why is it that bubbles pop? How
does um econ how do economies rise and
fall? Okay. So I'm not an exppert. I'm
not even a professor. Yes, I understand.
But what I do is I engage in speculation
for fun, for entertainment. Okay? So,
just see this as a fun class where we're
going to explore some fun topics that
have no scholarly basis. Okay? All
right. So, just keep this in mind, guys.
All right. So, let's look at very
quickly the main explanation for why
booms and buzz happens. And this is from
uh Andrew Ross Sulken who is probably
the most influential financial
journalist in America and he wrote a
book called 1929 which looks at the
stock market collapse of 1929 and he
offers a very good explanation as to why
it happened. Okay. So Emma, could you
read from me please? Of
>> course.
Lengthy uninterrupted booms like the one
in the 1920s produce a collective
delusion. optimism becomes a drug or a
religion or some combination of both.
People lose their ability to calculate
risk and distinguish between good ideas
and bad ones.
>> Okay, so again, this is a set
explanation for why there's a bubble
burst because it's illusional and then
it's like you fly too high, okay? But
you're you're not supposed to fly. So
then you fall down to the ground
eventually. It's just gravity, okay? The
idea of gravity. But I want to what I
want to show you today is there's
actually another explanation which is
this is all being engineered.
There are people behind the scenes who
have the power to cause economies to
rise and to fall. Okay, so let me give
you an example of this.
All right, let's just say you're a bank.
All right, you're a bank
and your job is to take those money,
save it, and then use it properly in
order to um promote the economy. Okay?
So, let's just say we put a million
dollars into the bank. Okay? And what
does the bank do with it? The bank then
lends it out to entrepreneurs,
right? So, maybe I want a restaurant and
I so I borrow a million dollars from the
bank.
Okay,
question. How much money is the bank
now?
It to be zero, right? Okay, that's
that's just math, guys. Look, if I take
in a million dollars and I lend it out a
million dollars, I should have zero cuz
that's just basic math. But that's not
the answer. The actual answer is $2
million.
And
what you need to understand is that each
bank has the ability to print its own
money and the bank is a mechanism for
liquidity in the economy. Okay.
And this is a great illusion. This is a
delusion. Okay.
um behind the economy where money is
just a is just an idea. It's a concept.
It's a collective hallucination.
All right. Um now, but the problem is
there are thousands, tens of thousands
of banks everywhere. So, how do they
know how to coordinate together? Okay.
And this is something else you need to
understand about the system. There's
actually something called a signaling
mechanism.
signaling
Okay. Um so all these banks are separate
but they are linked together into
something called a central bank. Okay. A
central bank
and what does central bank central bank
do? The central bank signals
whether or not to lend money or not to
lend money. And it's and this mechanism
is called the interest rate.
Okay. Now again if you study economics
what they will teach you is that
depending on the interest rate if it's
low maybe 1% or 5% or high 5% then that
will determine how consumers behave. If
the interest rate is 1% what this means
is I can go to the bank get money and
buy a house right? If it's too high 5%
then I don't want to go to the bank to
buy a house. And this is what you're
taught in in economics class. But
there's actually another explanation
which is the interest rate is not to
signal consumers or homeowners to buy
but rather for banks to lend or not.
Okay? It doesn't make sense because the
banks what they can do is depending on
the interest rate they know that okay my
job is to release more liquidity into
the system release more money into the
system and therefore I will make it
easier
to take out a loan. Okay. But if the
interest rate is high then I know okay I
must not release too much liquidity in
the system. Therefore I will make the
loan application hard. Okay.
So in other words, the interest rate is
not it is not set in order to guide
consumer behavior. It is set in order to
coordinate liquidity in the marketplace.
Okay, does it make sense? Okay, so these
are two very curious aspects of this
system that people don't really
understand.
So in order to understand the system, I
will explain to you how the world works.
Okay? And I explained this before but I
want to summarize and apply to this
scenario scenario. Okay. So the first
thing to understand is that we live in
Plato's cave.
Okay. Meaning that we're all chained to
the floor and we're all watching a
scream and behind is this great fire
where the elite create uh puppets for so
that we can collectively hallucinate our
own reality. All right. And this
mechanism
that allows us to coordinate our
imagination is of course called money.
Right? So think of money as
God. Right? And so what money is doing
is it's focusing our minds in a certain
way that creates our reality.
All right? So remember and remember this
idea and keep this in mind. Okay? So
because of this concept, this allows us
to create the world that we live in
today. Okay? So remember how the world
is structured. Um you have the empire,
but then you have the game masters.
Who are the game masters? They're the
people in finance.
Okay? Okay. And this includes Bank of
International Settlements,
uh, World Bank, uh, International
Monetary Fund, uh, Wall Street, Se of
London. Okay. These are different
financial organizations that coordinate
together and they are the game masters
and what they do is they control how US
dollars, which is the currency of this
game, they control how US dollars um,
moves around the system. Okay. So, USD
and this creates of course the global
economy.
But you cannot
allow people to think that they're
actually a set of people manipulating
this game because people will think this
is not fair. It's not transparent,
right? It's and it it's not a clean
game. So what you do is you create
multilateral organizations
called the rulesbased international
order like the WTO UN
and you make them believe that oh it's
these impartial
organizations that actually control the
game. So it's fair and it's transparent
and it's accountable to the people.
Okay. And then you reinforce this using
media,
um, education and culture.
And together these three will, um,
create the values and norms
that make us believe that this is a
fair, open, and transparent game in
which we can all win. Okay? So that when
there's a collapse, it's not because
there are people engineering this
collapse behind the scenes. It's because
it's a law of gravity. This this just
happens naturally in this game. It's no
one's fault. It's just like we were too
lazy and corrupt. Okay. All right. So,
certain things to remember about the
system is that this system is not as
clean as you think because there are
opposing forces to it. All right. And
these opposing forces are such forces
such as nationalism,
okay? or ethnic identity. Then you have
social democracy,
individual rights, right? And then and
then of course you have religion,
right? So there are these
counterveailing forces that try to break
apart the system. So then what happens
is that there are other um systems that
keep the system in place and respond to
these countervailing forces. All right?
And they are intelligence,
spies basically, crime and science.
And behind these three forces
are three sets of powerful institutions.
Okay, these are transnational capital
um secret societies
and the last is elite families.
Okay, some people call some people call
them the uh Illuminati. Okay, it doesn't
matter. All right, so this is how the
world works. And underpinning uh this
elite is something called the occult
which we'll study later on. Okay. All
right. So certain things that stand out
about the system that you may notice is
hey guys look
transnational capital
is also
the game masters as well as the global
economy. Okay, this is important because
remember this system is the parasite
and this system is a host.
So transational capital is both the
parasite as well as the host. It's both
the game master as well as the player.
Okay. So this obviously leads to a lot
of corruption.
So then the question then is how do we
get this system? Where the system come
from? So, so let me go into some
history. Okay, so the year is 1688
and this and and in Britain that's
called the Glorious Revolution.
Think of the Glorious Revolution as a
marriage between two empires, the
British Empire
and the Dutch Republic. Okay, England
and
Dutch Republic. At this point in
history, 1688, the Dutch Republic is the
richest area of the world because it
controls the spice trade. In this time
in history, spice is the most valuable
commodity. The problem with the Dutch
Republic is that it cannot defend itself
in Europe. Okay? It's easy, it's easily
invaded. It's also Protestant.
So and they are being attacked by the
Catholics, Catholic France, Catholic uh
the Catholic Church as well as the
Hapsburgs, the Holy Roman Empire. So
what they agree to do is they combine
they agree to combine their forces. All
right? So what happens is the wealth of
the Dutch Republic goes to England.
All right. in creative call in 1694
the church sorry the bank of England.
Okay. So this is a private bank
that is not accountable to the public.
What it does is this. It prints money
and who buys it? Parliament buys it.
Okay. And this is a massive innovation
that allows the British Empire to
conquer the world because before if
you're rich, if you get if you lend your
money to a king to fight wars, that was
dangerous because the king could die or
the king could lose the war or the king
could not pay you back. Okay? But if you
lend money to parliament, which is the
nation state, then you're guaranteed to
get your money back as long as
the nation is still around. Okay? And at
this time in history, England is the
safest area of Europe because it's an
island protected by the Royal Navy. All
right? Okay. So, this is an innovation
that forever changes human history. And
there are three major characteristics of
this system. Okay. The first is the idea
of
um profits
are prioritized,
losses
are socialized.
If you're a rich person in the world,
you want to put your money in the Bank
of England because there's no way the
Bank of England loses money. If England
goes fight a war and it loses, England
pays for it. But if it wins the war,
then you get the money for it. Okay? So
this is the first concept you need to
understand. All profits are prioritized.
All losses are socialized, picked up by
the nation state, the people. That's the
first thing. Second thing is
in this system, the way you generate
wealth is through activity. And what
does that mean? It means wars,
right? So if I give you money, you have
to go do something with it. You have to
go make more profit. And the way you do
that is through fighting wars. And
that's why um the British Empire started
to expand very quickly around the world
because it needed to generate profits
for the bankers. Okay. So this includes
of course the Napoleonic wars,
seven of them. It includes something
called the great game, a war between
Russia and Britain uh for control of
central Asia. Um and also India, the
conquest of India and then um the
conquest of
of China. Okay. Okay. Does it make
sense? The open wars.
All right. So profits.
So the second characteristic is like
you're always creating more activity.
All right.
Okay. And the third thing is it's
transnationalism.
Okay. Open borders.
So it believes that capital should be
able to move around from place to place.
It needs to build systems in order to
move capital from place to place. Okay.
And the last thing I want to talk about
is okay this is great for the bankers
but the people look at this and they
think that this is an unfair system
which it is right so now you have to
brainwash the people into believing this
is a fair system and that's why you
create a new idea called materialism
or money is god
and so what was happening was that
transnational capital bank of England
were sponsoring major intellectuals to
come up with the major ideologies to
support the idea that money is God.
Okay. And these include
um sorry uh John Lock
who argued that private property is a
god-given right. Okay. It is an inherent
right as much as freedom as much as
happiness. Okay. Um, and he's the
founder of of a theory called
empiricism.
And empiricism states that
we can only know what we ourselves
experience. It is not feasible. It is
not practical to try to come up with a
theory of the world beyond our
experience. So don't think about God
because God is beyond our experience.
Okay. Then you have someone named
uh David Hume. Okay. David Hume
and David Hume
argued for skepticism.
And skepticism just says that
everything that you know is actually not
valid because what you know is just just
based on
um your belief. Okay. So Rome is a
capital of Italy. Have you been to Rome?
Probably not. Okay. So where did you
learn this? you learn in school by
memorizing this fact. So basically we
should we should be skeptical of
everything we know because most of stuff
we know is either custom or habit. Okay.
So that's the idea of skeptism. So now
the problem is okay skeptism and parism
just means that we don't really know
anything and God doesn't really exist.
So how can we design society? And so
this creates a new idea called
udarianism.
We just say that if it is useful,
if it gives us pleasure, it must be
good.
Okay? If you if you take drugs and you
are happy with it, it must be good. If
you like spending money, it must be
good. Okay? And this is from Bantham.
And then John Stewart Mills will make
some will make some adjustments to it.
Okay? But this becomes the very concept
of liberty.
All right? Liberty just means that you
are free to pursue
as much money making as possible because
that is the ultimate good. That is what
gives you the most pleasure in life.
Spending money. Okay? That's what
liberty is. If a country prevents you
from making money and spending money,
it's an evil dictatorship.
A good country allows you to enjoy the
pleasures of making money. Okay. And
then um what will happen is that these
are the three major philosophers of
materialism
um of British liberty and then you'll
have people like Marx come in and
they'll introduce the idea of dialectic
materialism.
dialectic materialism
which is we just say like the world is a
is is one of class struggle. It's not
between God and us. It's not between the
divine and the material. It's one
between the poor and the rich and that's
it. Okay. So Markx is taking out the
divine from the equation. Then you have
um Darwin theor of evolution
which basically says we're just animals
man. Okay that's all. We're not divine
beings. We're all just animals. Then you
have you have people like Freud.
Sex is awesome, guys. Okay, that's what
we should be doing. We should be making
a lot of money and then having as much
sex as possible because that's what we
are. We're just apes. Okay. So, this
becomes very foundation
for the idea that money is God. All
right. Okay. So um what then happens is
that transnational capital which has
conquered the British Empire is now
seeking new opportunities for its
investments. Okay. So where it goes next
is of course America.
The problem is that the Americans just
had a revolution to destroy the American
to get rid of the British Empire. Right?
So the Americans don't want
transnational capital. it doesn't want
Bank of England or City of London to
come in and conquer it. So, so what
happens is the city of London, the Bank
of England, they use agents in America
and these agents of course are called
uh there's three of them. Okay. Well,
there's actually a lot, but these agents
include,
John Rockefeller,
Carnegie, okay, Andrew Carnegie,
um JP Morgan, Vanderbilt,
and they will by themselves
monopolize different industries with the
resources and the capital of the city of
London. in the bank of England. Okay. So
of course John Rockefeller monoposis is
oil. Okay. And then what will happen is
that these very powerful agents of um
the city of London will get together and
they will create a system model of the
bank of England and this of course is
called the Federal Reserve system.
All right.
and strange enough after the Federal
Reserve system uh is created three
things happen right the first is that
America enters World War I then you have
the 1929
um 1929 stock market collapse followed
by the great depression and 1941 America
joins World War II. Okay, do you
understand?
So Federal Reserve system means that
like Britain
um America is now controlled by
transnational capital,
right? And it's the same system now
where uh profits are prioritized, losses
are socialized
and where it's important to open the
country up to capital movement.
All right. Okay. So as we know America
wins World War II and what it does now
is that it tries to move the system
around the world specifically Japan and
Europe. Okay. Where where it is where
it's able to control
um the territory and eventually it
fights a cold war with the Soviet Union
but then it wins and then um it it
basically um after collapse of Soviet
Union for the next 20 30 years it has
complete control over the world
something we call a unipolar moment. All
right. And during the unipolar moment,
what happens is that um manufacturing
from America shifts over to China and
America completely focused on finance.
This leads to the 2008 great financial
crisis.
All right.
Okay. So, let me provide some background
about the financial crisis. Okay. You
don't you don't have to know everything.
I'm going to give you a lot of details,
but I just want you to understand the
basic structure of it. Okay. So what
allowed the great financial crisis to
happen is something called subprime.
Okay. Subprime just means that you're
lending money to people who can't pay
you back. Okay. In this context, it's
lending people lending money uh to poor
people to buy homes. And before banks
didn't want to do that. Okay. But there
are certain things that happen to make
subprime
um happen. Okay. So the first thing is
that Bill Clinton
he really wanted to increase minority
ownership of homes. Okay? He wanted
black people to buy more homes. But
again, black people were historically
poor. So the banks didn't really lend
money to them. And that's why uh Bill
Clinton encouraged the government to
help minority homeowners uh sorry
minorities buy homes. Okay. So that's
the first thing. Okay. And this this was
a noble goal. The second thing that
happened which is more important is in
1999 Bill Clinton repealed something
called the Glass Stagle
Act. And what is this? The glass stagle
act just said that if you are a bank
and you take money
from depositors you cannot engage in
risky lending. Okay. If you are a
investment bank okay if you're a retail
bank you cannot engage in risky lending
but if you're an investment bank a
private bank you can engage in risky
lending. And so that's what the act
said. Okay, it's it's trying to mitigate
risk in the system. But by repealing the
god stable act, what what you do is you
combine retail and investment together.
And so these banks now become very
large. And once they become very large,
they need to create financial vehicles
in order to generate more profit. Okay?
And at the same time, what's happening
is that because America has the unipolar
moment, everyone wants to invest in
America because they think America is
the safest place to put your money.
Okay, so this includes the GCC, the uh
China, Europe, and its pension funds and
also Japan. Okay, Japan is investing in
America something called the yen carry
trade.
And this is one of the dumbest things in
the world because at this time in
history, Japan is suffering from
deflation, right? No one spending any
money. So what the government does is
that it lends money out to institutions
at 0% interest.
Okay.
Now, the institutions are supposed to
take this money and promote more
liquidity in the system. But instead
what they do is they take this money and
use it to borrow or buy US treasuries
which provide 5%.
Pay. Okay? So you're borrowing money at
0% and then lending it out at 5%. And
it's something called the yen carry
trade. Okay? It's one of the dumbest
things in the world. Um we we won't go
into it but again there's massive money
coming into the US financial markets and
they need to create more investment
vehicles for investors okay and they
create something called the CDOS's
which means collateral debt obligations
okay but basically it just means
subprime
right
um the idea is is that mortgages are a
good investment because people have to
pay a monthly mortgage Therefore, you're
guaranteed certain money at the end of
the month. Okay. The problem of course
is subprime could lead to default.
Okay. But at this time in history, no
one was concerned about default because
of the idea of
too big to fail.
Which means that look the system is
structured so that everyone is involved
and if these homeowners default the
banks default then the entire economy
collapses.
Okay. So the idea is too big to fail the
system will keep on going because if a
certain percentage of homeowners were to
default the entire housing market would
collapse. Okay? Doesn't make sense guys.
All right. So this is one big Ponzi
scheme.
But we know for a fact that in 2008
this system collapsed.
And for the longest time what we
believed is it's because the defaults
were too many. They were too much. And
so the system had to collapse.
But if you look at what happened, what
you will discover is that's not true.
Okay? The banks could just choose to
roll over the default. Okay? Meaning,
okay, you owe me $1,000, right, for the
mortgage, but you can't pay me. What do
I do? Well, I say, "Pay me back next
month." Right? You're like, "Next month,
you can't pay me back. Don't worry. Pay
me back the month after." Okay? I can
have the system keep on going because
remember the system this money is is
just based on an illusion. Doesn't make
sense, guys. All right.
But but it collapsed.
Okay. So that's something that we're
going to look at today. All right. So as
you can see from this um map um this
chart at first what was happening was
that um the government was the one
issuing out uh loans. Okay so the
government is basically light blue but
then because this industry was so
profitable private banks started to come
in and issue their own loans and these
became very risky loans. Okay.
And this led of course to 2008 when the
entire thing collapsed.
Okay. All right.
So
the the big question is why did the
financial market collapse? So this is
the CDO is issuance. Okay. As you can
see it's generating a lot of money for
these private banks and then suddenly in
2008 there's this massive default. It
collapses. The question is why this
happen? And again, you're taught in ALS
class. This is just a law of gravity.
Okay? If you go too high, you're going
to fall. But what people don't tell you
is this. They're actually people who
made a lot of money because of the
collapse.
John Paulson, how much money did he make
in this collapse?
$20 billion, guys. That's a lot of
money. $20 billion.
How did he make his money? He made his
money by betting that the house market
would collapse. You understand what
happened? Okay. So, so think about this,
okay?
I lend a million dollars to Amber. Okay?
And everyone, you have to pay back
$10,000.
But then suddenly you kept paying back,
right? But if I tell you, Amber, um, you
can't pay me back. You have to give me
your home. Okay? Then I lose my
investment in you, right? So, I don't do
that. I I keep on letting you live in
the house. Pretend that you can pay me
back even though you can't pay me back.
But then Vincent says to me, "Hey, Mr.
Jeff, I bet you that Amber will not
default on her loan because she hasn't
defaulted in the past 10 years." I say
to Vincent, "How much you want to bet
me?" And he's like, "Um, half a million
dollars." Okay. He's so confident that
you will not default. Right? So I say,
"Sure, Vinc, I'll take this bet with
you." Right? Now, what I do now I make
you default cuz now I can make a million
dollars from Vincent. And that's how it
work, guys.
You think it's a very complicated thing.
It's not. It's all a giant scam because
only a few people control the entire
system. This is how you make $20 billion
in this game. Okay? you there are stupid
people buying uh mortgages from you,
right? But you have even more stupid
people who bet that you will not default
on these mortgages and you so you take
your money from the stupidest people and
that's why the system collapsed because
you're going to make more money from
collapsing the system than just letting
it go on. Okay, this is this is John
Paulson.
This is
Jimmy Diamond.
and he also profited from the bank
collapse. Why? Because when these banks
collapse, you can start to consolidate
the banking industry. Okay? So JP Morgan
start to buy these other banks that were
losing money. And then JP Morgan now now
is the largest bank in America.
All right.
Also guys, look at this.
Before 200 and uh 8,
most homes were actually owned
by
individuals. Okay, this is 2008. Okay,
so so the gray are just individuals.
They might have one home, they might
have 10 homes, but there's basically
individuals.
The blue are those who own more than a
thousand houses. And then the dark blue
are those big banks that own like
100,000 of homes. Okay, so before 2008,
you can see like most people were in the
gray. Okay, these are just individuals.
But then after collapse, you see the
blue and the dark blue rot go way up.
Why? Because these homeowners lost their
homes. And so these banks and these
companies could come in and buy them on
the cheap. Doesn't make sense. So it's
not So the great financial crisis of
2008 destroyed millions of lives, but it
made it made it profitable for a few
powerful individuals and institutions.
Okay. All right. A major consequence.
So So then you're like, "Okay, no, no,
no, no, Mr. J, you don't get it. It's
gravity."
Eventually, a bubble has to collapse.
Well, okay. Well, today we have two
bubbles. We have something called the
private equity bubble,
private credit bubble, okay? Where
private banks lend money to private
companies. And people say it's $2
trillion.
And it hasn't collapsed yet. Why?
Because the private banks allow
the private companies who are losing
money to keep on going. You understand?
the the private banks don't come and
say, "Hey, you guys are losing money. I
you should declare bankruptcy and I'll
take whatever you have." Why? Because
they lose a lot of money that way. Okay?
Do you understand this idea? These
bubbles can keep on going forever.
They don't have to collapse. Another big
bubble today is something called the AI
bubble, right?
These companies, Nvidia, OpenAI, when
they their AI products don't actually
make any money. Like Cat Vita does not
make any money. In fact, it loses money
every every time you use it. Okay?
Because it's more expensive to run
chatbt than it generates in revenue. But
and it's it's a huge bubble, but why
does it collapse? Because these are just
a few companies lending money to each
other. Okay? That's all it is. It's a
giant Ponzi scheme. It's an inside game.
So, Bubbles don't have to collapse. They
collapse when it's profitable for a few
individuals to make it collapse. All
right. Okay. Another idea I want you to
understand is that
um after 2008 great financial crisis,
this created problems in the global
economy. And so what happened was
transnational capital decided to
to save the global economy by allowing
China to rise.
Okay, you got so this is not known but
one major consequence of the great
financial crisis is that trans capital
encouraged China to print money.
Okay. All right. So I'm going to show
you how but um but but first let's let's
talk about the main mechanism to allow
this happen. It's called the bank of
international settlements. Okay. And
this is um the bank of international
sentiments is in Bezos Switzerland and
it's considered
the central bank
of central banks.
So every nation has a central bank okay
that determines interest rate but the
BIS is the central bank of central banks
which coordinates all central banks. All
right and it is the most powerful bank
in the world. All right. And you think
that okay this must be public. No, it's
not public. It's just run
um in the best in it's managed for the
best interests of powerful people in the
world. Okay. All right. So um this is
from the book Basil Tower of Basil.
Okay. Uh C can you read? For despite uh
Hitler's blister and
planning, Nazi Germany had not achieved
a turkey. It needed to buy vast amounts
of raw materials to manufacture
armaments and to feed, heat, and clothe
its population. Swedish steel, Romanian
oil, Portuguese tungsten, even South
American beef all had to be purchased
and paid for in hard currency. Nazi
Germany needed a financial channel to
the neutral countries it ran through
basil which is the main reason why Nazi
Germany did not invade Switzerland or
Sweden. These neutral countries were far
more used to the third reach as
>> Third Reich Reich. Yes, Third Reich as
monetary hubs on the transnational
financial network than as extra swat
swather
swats of German controlled territory.
Okay. So, what this means is this. In
this speech is Hitler promised
independence from the global financial
order controlled by the British. Okay.
But you can't really do that because you
still have to buy things from other
places. But but then you're like, I need
a bank to uh lend me money to buy things
but also help me facilitate
transactions. Okay. And this is idea of
transational capital.
and transational capital, they don't
really care if you're evil. They don't
care. All they care about is how can I
make money. So this this bank, bank of
national settlements and transational
capital was helping to fund the Nazi war
machine because it was profitable to do
so. Okay, you think okay after Hitler
lost the Americans would surely know
okay bank of national sentiments is evil
because they help the Nazis therefore we
should destroy the bank of national
sentiments okay but that's not what
happened
after war i the national bank of
national settlements became even more
powerful okay all right can can you read
uh Amber
>> martial aid came at a price remodeling
European societies on the American model
of consumerism and consumption.
Hoffman's propaganda arm produced
pamphlets, posters, leaflets, radio
programs, and even traveling puppet
shows that extolled the American
lifestyle. The American dream, a house
in the suburbs, a car, and numerous
household appliances,
was projected as a near guaranteed
benefit of Americanstyled freedom. The
key to this was increased productivity
on Americanstyle production lines in a
transnational free market. For that to
happen and for the money to flow freely,
new mechanisms of international payment
had to be constructed with the BIS at
the center.
>> Okay. So the world is run for money.
Okay. The world exists, these
organization exists in order to
facilitate the easy fluid movement of
money around the world and make money
god. Okay. So after 2008 the bank of
national settlements had a problem in
that the global economy was slowing
down. Europe had lost a lot of money.
America had lost a lot a lot of money.
So their solution was let's shift the
center of gravity from America and
Europe to China. And you're like okay
how do you do that then? You do that
with something called the exchange rate.
Okay exchange rate is very simple. um
reming B
to USD.
Okay. So remember how the interest rate
in a national economy is a signaling
mechanism as to whether or not to
increase or decrease liquidity. Well,
the exchange rate in the international
marketplace is a signaling mechanism to
tell other nations
whether or not to trade with another
nation. Okay, does that make sense to
you guys? All right, so let's look at
what happened.
So for the longest time, the Chinese
currency was trading above eight to the
US dollar because remember the US dollar
is the main mechanism
um of global trade. And then hey
starting around this time 2008 guys it's
hard to
increase in value.
Okay and so now the world knows oh I
should trade with China and China is
like well okay my exchange rate is
higher than before therefore I should
buy more things from the world. Okay.
But not only that, but now that I have
access to commodities from the world
that then I should know I need to
promote my economy to use these
resources. So I should spend more money
on infrastructure. I should build more
highspeed railways. I should build
airports.
Okay? And that's what China did. You see
how 2008 just as the American and
European economies were suffering, the
global economy was suffering, the
Chinese economy
um uh China start to have a higher
exchange rate. Okay? And it kept on
going higher higher and higher and then
what what did China do it? China started
to buy stuff from around the world with
it. Okay. Again, this is a signaling
mechanism where the bank of national
sentiment is saying to the world you you
can now sell to China. We will guarantee
China.
All right? And and that's because the
bank national sentiment needed China to
buy more things from the world. And this
happened in starting around 2008, right?
This massive surge in imports
and because all these commodities were
coming to China, China to spend these
commodities. So started to build
infrastructure, right? And and how did
it finance the building of this
infrastructure?
Bank loans, guys.
Bank loans. All right. So, this is
China. Sorry.
This is This is China, right? Look at
this. Look, look, look at this. Look at
this. This is China.
2008. 2008.
Basically, China, US, Japan, Europe, the
economies were about the same. The bank
system is about the same. But starting
about 2008, wow,
look at this.
This is all being orchestrated by the
Bank of Natural Settlements, by a few
people working behind the scenes.
Look at this. Look how crazy this is.
All right. So, what what does this mean?
It means that today
China has the largest banks in the
world. This is JP Morgan, the largest
bank
in America.
This is Chinese. This is Chinese. This
is Chinese. This is Chinese.
This is Japanese.
Okay. The top four banks in the world
are Chinese.
Why? Because in the in the bank system,
debts are liabil sorry debt liabilities
are also assets. Do you understand
all this money the Chinese banks have
are just liabilities?
Okay.
So this is how the system works. It's
all just an illusion.
Um the thing about the Chinese system um
that prevents it from imploding is the
fact that all debt in China is localized
instead of nationalized. All right. So
even though these Chinese banks are
heavily in debt, it's they're they're in
debt in local areas, not national areas.
Okay? And all this means is that um the
bank of China does not have that much
debt relative to say the bank of Japan.
Okay? So debt in Japan is nationalized.
Debt in China is localized.
Right?
Okay. So another major consequence of
China um the Chinese the growth of the
Chinese um banking system is that China
start to export its goods around the
world more. Okay. So as you can see in
the year 2000
America
um really dominate the world in
manufacturer export. Okay. But by the
year 2024, look, it's basically the
entire world
um is buying Chinese exports.
All right? And so um this is a
deliberate strategy
of Chinese national capital to move the
center of economic gravity from the
United States to China.
And but the problem with China, the
reason why China has not become the
hedgeimon is that
China's not interested in being a hedge
man. In other words, military power.
Also, as China is expanding
um its manufacturing capacity to the
world, who's upset now? The United
States, right? And so what the United
States does is it imposes tariffs.
Okay? Does that make sense? All right.
So in other words, okay,
even though
in theory the theory is is that
the goal of the bankers
is to maintain the game. Okay, that's
all they care about. So they want to
switch from America to China, but it
didn't really work because China doesn't
really want to take the responsibility
of being the global reserve currency as
well as having military bases overseas.
All right? So China China doesn't want
to do this and America won't let China
do this.
So your only option now is Israel. Okay?
And that's why I believe that this war
in Iran, what it will do is shift the
center of gravity from America to Israel
because Israel wants to be the center of
the world, not China. Okay? Doesn't make
sense, guys. All right. The other thing
you have you have to understand is that
for this to happen though, transnational
capital needs to first collapse the
American economy. And there are
different ways they can do that, right?
They can collapse the private private
credit bubble, then they can collapse
the AI bubble. and collapse both at the
same time. And why would they want to do
that? Because as a banker, as
transational capital, you make your
money through activity, right?
When people go and do stuff, whether
it's entrepreneurship or starting wars,
but they have to go do stuff. And right
now, America has a lot of problems.
Okay? So, so let let's look at America's
problems.
First is aging, where the elite are now
older and older. They therefore they are
less active, they're less energetic,
they're less entrepreneurial. Okay? Then
you have something called quantum easing
which is too much money in the system.
You have too much money in the system
then people do stupid things like
gamble. Okay. All right. And the last
problem of America is you can't win
wars.
Okay. like this Iran situation is
showing that America the American
military is not as strong as you think
it is. So if you chan path you see these
few things okay the population is
getting too old uh there's too much
money around so people do stupid things
like gambling and America the American
military is not that great then you're
going to shift your capital from America
overseas okay but but before you do that
what you want to do is engineer a
financial crisis so that you can make as
much money as possible just like the
2008 financial crisis okay so we don't
know when it will happen but we're going
to be sure that it will happen it'll be
suddenly Okay.
Okay. It doesn't make sense, guys.
Now, you're like, "Wait a minute here.
Why Why would Trump and Americans allow
this to happen? They know. They must
know this is coming." And the answer is
because it is in the long-term best
interest of America for the economy to
collapse and for transnational capital
to go elsewhere. And this is something
we'll discuss next class. Okay. what the
long-term American strategy is.
Transational capital is leaving America.
So, and Americans are like, "Oh my god,
Bank of England, City of London, these
currencies are leaving. Thank you. Get
out of here, man." Okay. And what will
happen is once they leave, America will
probably have a much brighter future and
something we'll discuss next class. But
any questions?
Yep.
So, seems like that uh America is in a
disadvantaged situation, but the but
they know what they are doing and
they're just sending parasite out
outside of their country and having a
more long-term benefit. Is that right?
Okay. So, this something we'll discuss
next class. Okay. But this is not a
deliberate strategy.
All right. Because if you think about
it, economic collapse will destroy a lot
of wealth in America. It will probably
create conditions for civil war in
America. It will create a lot of pain.
But there are certain people, for
example, Donald Trump who believe that
this pain is necessary in order for
America to become great again. Okay? He
said his motto is what? Make America
great again. And how do you do that? You
get rid of these parasites. But to get
rid of parasites, guys, it's a painful,
painful process. It's like a cancer,
right? Have you guys been through cancer
treatment? It's painful. Chemotherapy,
they do surgery on you. You have to like
eat this, you know, crappy food all the
time. It's a painful process. Okay. So,
tential capital, it's a parasitic force.
It's a cancer on the American host. They
have to get rid of it, but it's going to
be a very painful process that that's
going to take a long time, years,
possibly decades. Okay. Yeah, Amber,
>> thank you. Um, so if transnational
capitals leaving America, then how would
you think this shift would impact the
global economy or would it at all?
>> Yeah. Okay.
All right. Yeah. All right. So, this is
something we'll discuss later on. Okay.
But let me just show you how the shift
happens. All right. So, right now you're
you're in America.
And the best place for you to shift is
Israel.
Okay? Why? Because
you're interested in activity. Okay?
You're interested in putting your money
in a place where it's going to grow,
right? And why is growing? Well, because
of the greater Israel project,
right? right? He wants to conquer the
Middle East, but then he has to rebuild,
right, after the after the war
rebuilding
and then what it's going to do is become
the hub of global trade, right?
Because Israel controls Africa. And this
is something we'll discuss next class.
Okay?
So, this is why you want to invest in
Israel for these three reasons. Why?
because they're going to keep on
fighting wars to make to achieve the
greater project. Wars are profitable.
Wars are the most profitable enterprise
in the world. Okay. Second is that they
have to rebuild after all the destru
after all this destruction. So they need
capital. The third is they will control
global trade because because of the
location. Okay. So this is why Israel is
a smart investment for transational
capital. I'm not talking about like us,
okay, with like $1,000. I'm talking like
trillions of dollars will probably go
into Israel. All right. So,
um, to leave America, what you want is a
stock market collapse. Okay? An an
economic collapse.
Why?
Because economic collapse not only
allows you to leave with a with a with
as much money as possible, but also
allows you to buy up distressed assets.
And when I mean distress acid, I mean
resources
which include uh water, oil. Okay. So
you want to create as much damage as
possible because then it's easier to for
you to buy up these resources and Okay,
does that make sense? Right. So these
guys plan decades ahead. But
transational capital, what what they're
what what they do is they're trying to
create as much chaos as possible because
in chaos there's profit. Like everyone's
sitting around doing nothing, you can't
make any money. Okay? But if people are
fighting each other, there's blood on
the streets, you can make a lot of
money, right? Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Any more questions, guys? Okay. So we'll
talk about um what happens after this uh
financial shift next class.